do you know what movie I loved a
hangover oh yes I loved it too
it's about guys who can't remember what
happened to them after a night of
binging do you movie I loved the
hangover our next two presenters are two
young actresses who have no idea who we
are please welcome Amanda Seyfried and
Miley Cyrus
tonight celebrates the 75th year of the
Best Original Song category among the
winning writers Rodgers and Hammerstein
Elton John Stephen Sondheim Isaac Hayes
Barbra Streisand Eminem they won not
just for writing a great song but for
writing a great song specifically for a
motion picture to serve us best specific
function in the movie we're both kind of
nervous is our first time on the stage
let's just look at how these songs were
used in those movies whether sung by
real people animated people or animated
real people here are the nominees for
Best Original Song
almost there from The Princess and the
Frog music and lyric by Randy Newman
down in New Orleans from The Princess
and the Frog music and lyric by Randy
Newman lawanda pnom from Paris 36 music
by Reinhardt vogner lyric by Frank
Thomas take it all from nine music and
lyric by Maury yes ten the weary kind
from crazy heart music and lyric by Ryan
Bingham and t-bone Burnett
and the winners are Ryan Bingham and
t-bone Burnett Crazy Heart
this is the first Academy Award
nomination for Ryan Bingham and this is
the first Oscar and second nomination
for t-bone Burnett
thank you so much I'd like to thank my
wife Anna I love you more than rainbows
baby yeah my uncle clay my band Jack
Wiggum Scott Cooper the cast of crazy
heart
Jeff and Maggie and Colin and mr. Bob
everyone at Fox Searchlight and mr.
t-bone Burnett and Stephen Britten
thank you all so much
you